le voilà le voilà le
voil pour les petites filles les petits
garçons j'ai mis un cllaxon dans le fond
de mon
pantalon je sais jouer les
imbciles TR d'automobile il rigole quand
je m'assoie
ou là là là là et comme ça en amusant
les petits bébés j'ai fait la
connaissance d'une jolie pépé la blatipa
qui m'invite je m'en va chez la petite
on s'assoit sur le sofa ou là là là là
au coup d'éclaconne arrive le
papa il me dit faut pas jouer au clown
avec moi mais pendant qu'il me
housouspille j'y demande la main de sa
fille rieny penser ça m chie ou là là là
j'ai fait une drôle de GAF ou là là
c'était son mari c'était pas son papa il
m'a sorti un coup de pompe ça fille
actionner la trompe qu'est-ce que j'ai
pris ce jour-là ou là là là là ou là là
là là ou là là là là ou là là là ou là
là ou là là là là